the drop all right one of the world's
biggest dance music festivals it is back
here in town it's the Electric Daisy
Carnival up at Las Vegas Motor Speedway
Festival craters Insomniac celebrating
30 years of work with some new additions
to the show this year so we find Candace
Charles this morning from hotel EDC good
morning
good morning folks yes this Festival
season I'm taking inside some of the
hottest festivals that hit Vegas and you
can't do it without of course EDC Las
Vegas which as Heather mentioned is
celebrating a huge accomplishment
Insomniac creators behind it all
celebrating 30 years taking Festival
goers to a deeper world inside of EDC as
well as Nevada Community getting a
closer look
foreign
[Music]
is all around you the goodness is all
around you peace
and respect a mantra that you won't only
see at Electric Daisy Carnival but feel
nothing is like the crowd at EDC
Insomniac the guests are actually called
the headliners because the fans are
truly what uh bring everybody together
Insomniac founder Pascal Rotella started
EDC in 1997 as a warehouse party in LA
it now brings hundreds of thousands to
Las Vegas speedway for a three-day
Festival you get to
see people you know really celebrating
life and being in the moment and sure
that does happen in other places in the
world but not like this more than 230
artists and DJs take on 14 stages we're
stepping into different worlds you know
you have the kinetic field the neon
Gardens circuit grounds Daisy Lane
rainbow road for the 30th Anniversary
Camp EDC returns there are five new
stages over on the Strip the ultimate
home for Headliners Hotel EDC vibey's
trying to leave every headliner going
home
just waiting to come back to hotel EDC
next year here in Las Vegas EDC is
partnering with destination experience
company vibey for a takeover of Resorts
World I like to call it the Super Bowl
of EDM music and dance music in Las
Vegas and if EDC is the Super Bowl Brett
freeze the executive director of
entertainment for Resorts World and Zoo
group is definitely one of the coaches
with a lineup of curated parties at AU
and outside transfix here you'll find
the nest which will have speed dating
and feature up-and-coming DJs
and here it is folks The Nest here at
hotel EDC you can do your makeup over
here there'll be some upbecoming DJs as
I mentioned they even have a wellness
center with meditation and yoga
Insomniac really it's all about the
health they're trying to keep people
healthy they're working within overdose
to make sure that they do continue to
help unfortunately at some of these
events accidental overdoses are quite
common of course we have to cover more
details on our website itnewsnow.com but
for now live from Resorts World where
Hotel EDC is I'm Candace Charles it is
now